many see the search for universal truths
about the world as the noble aim of
philosophy yet our universities largely
dismissed non Western philosophy and
critics argue that British students are
taught a narrow analytic approach our
great ideas independent of time place
and tradition do African conceptions of
the self or Chinese moas logic offer
equally valid insights do we need to
wake up to Western prejudice or is there
only one right way to think let me
introduce our speakers Timothy
Williamson is wickham professor of logic
at the University of Oxford and a
world-renowned philosopher of language
and logic Chakravarthi Ramprasad is
distinguished professor of comparative
religion and philosophy at lancaster
university and a fellow at the british
academy he is an expert in indian
philosophy and works on how philosophy
and different traditions can learn from
each other
anivia manchanda is a lecturer in the
school of politics and international
relations at Queen Mary University of
London she's an expert on how knowledge
is classified and racialized throughout
history so let's start with you Ron do
you think we need to wake up to Western
prejudice or is there any one right way
to think I think first of all I don't
see those two as opposed
I think philosophies are prejudiced
whether it's Indian or Chinese or
Western or Islamic because most of the
productions of knowledge especially in
the past and to some extent now depend
upon institutions patronage access which
narrows down who are the people who are
allowed to speak and therefore I do
think that patterns of thought tend to
be prejudiced that doesn't necessarily
mean they want to be do want to look
beyond what specifics are of your
upbringing and your training and you
want to speak to the human condition
having said that it does mean that we
have to entertain the possibility that
there are many different ways of being
right on different things it depends on
what it is we've been thinking about if
you're going to say is it right to think
you can walk through the fabric of this
tent there's only one answer to it and I
don't know whether anybody in China or
Africa would have come up with anything
different but what we take to be the
questions worth thinking about certain
amount of overlap different traditions
might give different answers and there's
there's as much conversation within any
particular philosophical tradition as
there are between them so I think we
should do the very boring thing and say
well what does it mean to think what are
the kinds of troops we are talking about
what do we mean by truth and how many
times we can just disagree on these
things which is I suppose what
philosophers do anyone might weigh to
think I think the idea that there's any
one right way to think for all the
questions that you might want to answer
is ridiculous although that doesn't mean
that nobody holds it I mean you know if
if you want to answer a question in
mathematics then a mathematical
mathematical way of thinking is
obviously right and a historical way of
thinking is wrong but if you want to ask
answer a question in history then a
historical way of thinking is is right
and a mathematical way of thinking is
wrong and that applies in in philosophy
as as well so for example in if you're
doing the philosophy of sense perception
then you're going to want to know about
the the psychology of sense perception
and and that kind of experimental way of
thinking it's gonna be very relevant to
your answer whereas if if you're
interested in a question in logic then
again actually a more mathematical way
of thinking will be better so there is
no one right way of thinking for all
questions and even for a one particular
question that there may be several
different ways of answering it you know
even within mathematics for example
there are you know geometrical ways of
thinking and algebraic ways of thinking
all which can get to the right answer of
a given question so so no but of course
some ways of thinking are better than
others and if we didn't accept that we
wouldn't be in a position really to to
criticize any way of thinking I mean as
for the waking up from Western prejudice
I suspect that talking about Western
prejudice would be about as useful as
talking about Eastern prejudice it's
just lumping so many different things
together that it's not a very helpful
category I mean I think in our thinking
we make all kinds of assumptions that we
that we don't reflect on then then that
prejudice in that sense is something you
simply can't avoid because you could
never be fully reflective and aware of
everything that you're assuming and
aware of everything you're assuming in
the in in that awareness and so on ad
infinitum so you know I think it's also
it's also the case that talking about
waking up from prejudice makes it sound
much easier than it really is because it
makes it sound as though all you really
have to do is a prick yourself with a
pin and you wake up from your prejudices
but actually I identifying ways in which
you've been relying on false assumptions
which is that's the key thing it's a
very important thing to do but it's also
a very difficult thing to do thank you
yeah thanks I just want to say that I'm
interested in international politics so
for ideas for me matter in what they do
politically and therefore I find the
question quite interesting because I
don't think that's one right way to
think I agree with Tim and Rahm but if
there was one then this the formulation
of this question suggests that that way
is Western so do we need to wake up from
Western privilege or is there only one
right way to think it doesn't allow you
to say actually maybe the only right way
to think is an African traditional
thought or Eastern traditional for not
that I'd like to say that but it signals
that Western hegemony is so normalized
that is the only way in which we are
allowed to express ourselves
and then the the other thing I want to
say is that absolutely we need to wake
up to prejudice but it's not that it's
not as easy as exactly as what Tim says
because prejudice is so inculcated so
when we think about the works of Kant or
mill who are prominent Western
philosophers what they wrote about
utilitarianism in the case of mill or
the ontology in the case of Kant were
deeply based on their ideas of
colonialism and slavery so you can't
take away the political context from
philosophy from thought at all thank you
I mean this brings us to our first theme
which is about the nature of philosophy
really and what we're doing when we do
philosophy and so our philosophical
truths Universal and if you yeah um well
I think it's pretty clear that I don't
think they're universal they are
absolutely time and context dependent
that doesn't mean that they can't
advance knowledge or can't give us
correct roadmaps and ways of thinking
but they are fairly Universal and I'm
going to be a bit of a millennial here
and pick up my phone to read a quote
from quite prominent thinker of
indigenous truths and she writes Linda a
howl right from the vantage point of the
colonized a position from which I write
I quote and choose to privilege the term
research is inextricably linked to
European imperialism and colonialism the
word itself research is probably one of
the dirtiest words in the indigenous
world's vocabulary when mentioned in
many indigenous contexts it stirs up
silence it conjures up bad memories it
raises a smile that is knowing and
distrustful it is so powerful that
indigenous people even write poetry
about research the ways in which
scientific research is implicated in the
worst excesses of colonialism remains a
powerful remembered history for many of
the world's colonized peoples it's a
history that still offends the deeper
sense of our humanity just knowing that
someone measured our faculties by
thinning the skulls of our ancestors
with millet seeds and compared the
amount of millet seed to the capacity
for mental thought offends our sense of
who we are and what we are it calls us
that Western research
and electrodes can assume to know all
that is possible to know of us on the
basis of their brief encounters with
some of us this is a tradition the
Western tradition in which I've been
trained to so I have to constantly teach
myself and comment on that that these
traditions are have been rarefied that
they come from somewhere and often they
come from very dirty and violent places
yep
well I think your well has to be very
careful about what is meant by universal
truths I mean of course it's it's
clearly true that certain ideas are ones
which we can only can only be had in
certain historical social circumstances
I mean so there was there was no chance
of people in the Stone Age coming up
with quantum mechanics for example and
and I think that's really absolutely
clear but but that doesn't mean that you
know just because the the truth or the
the principles that we come up with
could only be come up with in in certain
circumstances that that they're not
truths about all time and all space for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at AI TV
you